cac avait promis 15 mille logements elle
en a livré la moitié
je vous dirai qu'une chose si j'avais
embauché l'acca qu'on me construire une
maison je pense que je les enverrais
pour cris contre est ce que gabriel
nadeau dubois a raison de dire que la
caq n'a pas construit autant de
logements sociaux qu'elle l'avait promis
oui c'est vrai
en 2018 la plateforme de la cac ne
contenait aucun engagement officiel en
matière de logement mais dans une lettre
envoyée à des syndicats et vous ferez
preuve groupe de défense des locataires
la formation politique s'est engagé à
terminer la construction de quatorze
mille logements annoncés par le
gouvernement libéral précédent selon le
dernier bilan de la société d'habitation
du québec ses 5700 logements sociaux et
abordables qui ont été construits depuis
2018 même si on ajoute 3500 unités qui
devraient être livrés dans les prochains
mois on est bien loin des 14000 évoqué
par la cac il ya 4 à des quinze mille
logements sociaux et abordables sont
financés ils sont soit construit soit en
train d'être construit dans son dernier
budget le gouvernement indique que la
construction de 8000 unités déjà
annoncés n'étaient toujours pas commencé
à la fin décembre
les coûts de construction pour un
logement social ont explosé dans les
trois dernières années à montréal par
exemple ils sont passés de 200 milles à
286 milles dollars par unité plus la
construction tarde plus ça coûte cher en
ce moment au québec plus de 37 des
ménages sont inscrits sur la liste
d'attenté pour avoir une place dans un
logement subventionné qui permet de
payer le loyer équivalent à 25 % de
leurs revenus